well it's all over the internet and it's
all over the news wires you've seen the
story Fox Business comm reports it this
way Americans are dying with an average
of 62 thousand dollars in debt you seen
the story if you've been on Facebook or
Twitter you've seen the story it's
everywhere you're probably going to die
with some debt in your name most people
do in fact 73 percent of consumers had
outstanding debt when they were reported
as dead
according to December 2016 data provided
by credit com the credit bureau Experian
those consumers carried an average total
balance of 61 thousand five hundred
fifty four dollars including mortgage
debt without home loans the average
balance was twelve thousand eight
hundred seventy five dollars these were
the average unpaid balances credit cards
of 4531 auto loans of seventeen thousand
one hundred eleven personal loans of
fourteen thousand seven hundred and
ninety three and student loans of
twenty-five thousand three hundred and
ninety one that's a lot of debt and it
doesn't just disappear when someone dies
yes it does but the most part your debt
dies with you but that doesn't mean it
won't affect people you leave behind
debt belongs to the deceased person or
that person's estate says estate
planning attorney if someone has enough
assets to cover their debts the
creditors get paid and the beneficiaries
receive whatever remains but if there
aren't enough assets to satisfy the
debts creditors lose out they may get
some but not all of what they're owed
family members do not then become
responsible for the debt let me say that
again family members do not then become
responsible for the debt as some people
worry they might that's the general idea
so what when you die what you own when
sold off pays off your debts and what is
left over the net of that called your
net worth is passed to your heirs the
number of times people call me on the
radio
show here and say my dad has been
irresponsible his whole life he lives in
an apartment renting has absolutely no
money owns nothing doesn't even own a
car he's 86 and he has a hundred
thousand dollars in credit card debt am
I going to be liable for that credit
card debt
no that means that credit card companies
are stupid because they're going to get
zero when that man dies is no assets to
sell to pay his liabilities
he owns nothing to sell to pay what he
owes what you own stands good for what
you owe whatever's left goes to the
heirs between the two and so if your
mother passes away with $40,000 in
credit card debt but she owns a $100,000
house you don't get to keep the house as
the heir unless you pay the $40,000 of
credit card debt because what she owns
has to be sold to pay for what she owes
and if you want to keep the house yet to
pay what she owed otherwise it would
have to be liquidated to pay her debts
have to be sold to pay her debts
so well that doesn't seem fair well it's
course it's fair what you own stands
good for what you owe that's called a
balance sheet it's also how a net worth
is derived when what you own minus what
you owe equals a million dollars then
you are a millionaire if what you own
minus what you owe equals a billion
dollars then you are a billionaire which
is a thousand million by the way that's
a lot and you know the problem is is
that we've got a bunch of idiots running
around the culture for instance so that
thing of what a week or two ago with
Trump's tax returns that came out and I
think it showed he made 152 million
dollar income or something like that and
we had these morons in the press going
well he's not a billionaire II only made
152 million your income has nothing to
do with the calculation of billionaire
status morons
cheese people in the press it doesn't
have anything to do with that and these
are people on MSNBC which was supposedly
a business thing a business well over
it's not even close but I mean or CNBC
you want to know better I mean for God's
sakes don't tweet about stuff like that
it's just stupid okay so what you own
minus what you owe and so what does this
headline Americans are dying with an
average of sixty two thousand dollars
and that that is what's known as a
shocker headline it's sort of shock you
know Americans are all in debt and then
you read it and says it includes the
mortgage and without the home loans the
average balance was twelve thousand and
by the way do most homes have are they
worth more than is owed on them yes so
what this means is is that it's very
likely according to this particular
piece of data but we have a shocker
headline Americans are dying with an
average of 62 thousand dollars in debt
but that includes their home mortgage
and twelve thousand dollars of it is not
the home mortgage on average do you
think the average home in America has
more than twelve thousand dollars worth
of equity yeah
it's a pretty safe assumption so if if
the average home has more than twelve
thousand dollars worth of equity and the
average person is dying with twelve
thousand dollars worth of debt they are
dying with a positive net worth all
their debts are getting paid based on
what we just talked to you just now okay
so not so much of a shocker headline
it's pretty much of a yawning headline
except that it on stall over the
Internet this is the kind of you know
what we do is we just go for the
salacious now something to just get
everyone fired up and I should try that
I might be good at it if I tried it I
could probably come up with crap like
that that just is hyperbole and just
throw it out there and see if Americans
are dying from credit cards every day
plastic toxins are bleeding into your
skin because all you do is play
plastic between your fingers all day
long it's causing cancer I can probably
do stuff like that and find some more
thing that and then when you actually
read the actual data from the study it's
completely not true but it would be a
fun salacious headline right to get
things get everybody upside and you know
as we all know salacious headlines work
really well on Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram
you know BES in other words right and so
that's pretty much what this is from
Experian thank you Experian you got your
name out there again so your PR team is
doing its work and brought to you by the
people who develop the FICO score thank
you very much
yeah do you see a theme here and I do
okay so Americans are dying with an
average of 62 thousand dollars in debt
and an average of more than that in
assets does that make it you make you
yawn a little bit more it should just go
ahead and goes back to sleep now this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]